back off my broccolini get your life
together
I'm not touching
you think waterboarding would hurt that
much I've always wanted to get it done
to me I've talked about how what Tim can
do it to me and then I was in Austin
like a year ago and he text me goes send
address I did not send the address I was
scared
does he dot you know he does it like
that's really what he does she sent me a
picture of him in a van and his boys is
like did you do it I would do it for
like an afternoon or something I don't
think I would do like a couple of I
wouldn't do like a retreat I don't want
to do it before a show I don't want be
scared or it might make you wake you up
I think they just drip water on you what
do they do chin do you know they put a
towel over your face collar a face and
then they just constant constant flow of
water so it's the closer you come to
drown yeah really really makes you panic
you can't breathe your nose your mouth
yeah but you can't die right uh I don't
know it you could probably die hmm
what are y'all talking about I've heard
of waterboarding no god damn you ever
seen zero dark thirty no never seen
blackfish did they do that in blackfish
that's they kept doing it to the fish I
guess damn I know clogged in there
[__] blow holes dude you look like a
straight-up s-- lumberjack today do you
look like somebody that's supposed to go
to work and just goes and sleeps in the
woods that's good yes Brody you look
like a frickin you look like a regional
manner for Volk regional manager you
fumbled the words bye sorry it was a
joke
how'd you do do what are you in what do
you think is Cabo in the West what is
that dude is western style Brendan you
look like you you look like you go to
rehab for [__] my cards lemonade
anymore
it's still lemonade ya heard if you
drink a thousand you get to meet Mike
did you know anyone who drinks my cards
lemonade have you ever met a buddies I
did I'm just dying from those my cards
ever bro you look like that black girl
in the last episode you got busted going
back to school
booger McFarland bro you look just like
that lady like you're trying to be an
11th grade
that makes Theo Joe tessitura that's
right what is it far Joe Tessa Tori are
the monday night announcers are they
leaving booger McFarland is announcer
people get them because it makes
comments like this
the [__] pagers be up 17 ago and what
the patrons need to do is continue
playing ball if they want to get done
with this game just like ran but like
boy these boys are sweating if you ask
me it's like all right dude well LSU
Tiger though didn't want to tell us
human that's one thing doesn't get the
past of me though you know [__] damn you
boy your boy Joe Perillo ballin when I
say ball and I mean not doing anything
with that it wins the draft coming up
the draft is April hmm you know what Tom
Bynes right now and your boy Joe barrows
like now I'm not doing that yeah I
wouldn't do it no me neither
his whole season only hurt mine it can
only hurt ya bro we know what's coming
up is st. Patrick's Day oh and you know
what's up st. Patty's Day
birthday yeah oh you know what's after
your birthday dude my birthday I see
Bros 19th butchers 1813 nope I see
brothers start show swimming in the
world we save a ton of poker
just a couple Pisces boys hopped up on
fish swimming through the universe where
my [__] do all the lyrics staple to
the wall right now I'm telling I could
not see I'm I could not weekend that
happen was at two weeks ago I could not
sir I just bead randomly driving
laughing years ago here's and then
you'll our text each others rarely years
ago take steel back is this live each
other yeah nobody even knew what I was
talking about there I think I said it on
stage a couple times a couple weeks ago
that's the hardest I've ever laughed man
are y'all celebrating st. Patrick's or
what man quit trying to bypass what I'm
talking about you right dawg yes my dude
are you doing seeing for your bday what
should we do for our B days dude no dude
st. Patrick's is before our birthdays
know kind of steals our shine doesn't it
we just can't jump over a whole nation
of people the Irish well they don't
celebrate Saint Patrick's Day but that's
fun they make fun of the way you know
who st. Patrick was who was it Nick he
ran all the snakes out of Ireland yeah
oh yeah so [__] thank God doctor you
imagine being completely wasted and to
be a bunch of snakes around
you imagine drinking a beer of Guinness
and a cobra but thank st. Patrick good
you know how to spell Saint Patty's
that's always controversy around this
time Oh PA ddy yes huh that's right PA
like like patty like the patty of the
fighter remember yeah yeah patty :
oh you some guy that's one reason how to
spell PA d potty potty potty and what do
you how do you don't you know Oh Padre
Oh Bobby get in my belly
there's also patty pimblett another
patty Beverly Irish you have second oh
and there's a paddy wagon too if you
have to get Irish people and they don't
want to go with you well that's just
uber are you gonna do anything for your
bday dude who's gonna make me sad yeah
you since I was a kid wait am I in this
past weekend what am i doing welcome to
this past weekend today's episode is
brought to you by Craig walk
spread to you by Brendan's birthday any
sad days never look the high board
someone forgets it like my dad forgot it
last year whatever well let's talk about
st. Patty's Day dude so what are you
guys doing the culture corner for st.
Patrick's Day I want to get what do
y'all do let's drink green beer I'm
sober ah same here
no you're not straight dad don't jump on
his train yet problems he'll be fine
he's an adult
yeah you're fine the only time I feel
like I drink is when I'm out with you
and the guys oh that's it like I don't
really drink in my personal life there
boy drinks hard
yeah meetings for me ah but what can't
you guys don't do that celebrate st.
Patrick's Day does it cross over to
Asian culture or no Jim Jim will you
slurp down some green sake or what you
know I drink every day so that's not
gonna change but yeah I'll definitely
get some green beer with friends chin
you know what I've been really into it
uh Japanese whiskey it's my new kid and
this company is sent me a bunch of
bottles and bring it over oh really
Regis Studio I got into it because of
Jay to his
brother yeah my brother got into of what
it's called we say it it's called Nika
and I can't call a hook it up before I
get in trouble for you ever had Nika I
can ikka Nika coffee whiskey to your
defense there's a there's a Korean word
that sounds exactly like that - okay
[__] [__] it means like well that's me
Oh [__] yeah [__] came to me [__]
means you whiskey and the commissioners
on yeah I'm not this racist
dude it's a whiskey I'm not that's it
I'll tell you this Rick Lee I'm not
ordering it ever oh I just go is that uh
is that that Japanese whiskey though
which one come on you know what's wrong
man come on that one you know there's a
black bartender point over here like
what about in the urban community a
celebration Patrick's Day it seems like
it on celebrating I mean black people in
Arizona do yeah you know how I'm
celebrating it awesome Texas dude that's
your gonna be yep all weekend Thursday
Friday Saturday for my bday um are you
gonna work it on your birthday yeah I
like to bring in holidays I don't know
what I'm gonna do
oh no I'm worried about st. Patrick's
Day right now yeah you're stuck on st.
Patrick days because it's coming just
for but I just jump over it because I'm
looking forward to my birthday yeah if
that's how you I'm not that kind of guy
well let's let's say we have to look
forward to your birthdays or something
you want to do for your birthday
probably some shoes for you might get an
ice cream cake samples on okay I know
that's I know I'm asking if I can do you
a favor and give you a gift and give you
some cool shoes yeah I'll take some swag
we wear them though yeah
sauna bath 10/10
it's most popular size so is it cost
daddy some money but you've a strong
giver
it's a strong ten what else is going on
man we still alive from Corona nobody
told you I told you guys nothing to
worry about
Jin's brother sent him [__] tax gone
dude did you stock up on spam and sake
yeah that's what I want one of the
world's [__] breaking down spam yeah
did message me though to get plenty of
water
I'm sake I'm saying bro yeah dude
there's a there's a down-low information
system out there and that we are not on
Brendan you don't know what's going on
Jay's on Chin's brother drives a
Godzilla car he does anyone know what I
got diligent four three two one too late
Godzilla he's a fighter it's a Nissan
GTR hmm I used to play that game where
you would like make a sound and get have
people guess if it was Japanese or not
like yeah and see if it's a word in
Japanese you know yeah well you've got
too much of Jacko's magic Japanese
whiskey my favorite you bail it out man
hey Nick how would you do if I don't
lose all my jobs let's saying Nick like
that might you put at the bottom in
subtext n ikka that's popular right now
my favorite whiskey
okay there's several companies producing
whiskey in Japan but the two best-known
and most widely available or Suntory and
Nika both of these produce blended as
well as single malt whiskies and blended
malt whiskies oh so Dora there you go
you just shout it what's better let's
get into this episode dude before before
I lose my job yeah
do you want anything for your birthday
though besides shoes yeah let me think
about it man oh yeah would probably like
something I'm probably gonna get an ice
cream cake oh dude well that's what I
like yeah I like guys you also like
cakes from Susie's Susie pies I had
those these cupcakes right yeah but you
can get a cookie that they put icing all
over
Oh mrs. field Stewart do it you spell
your name on [__] I like those cookies
from the mall that you get your name
written on it this is field field cookie
cakes forever we used to go to the
roller rink for our birthdays now and
then you see the hot girl yeah so
embarrassing she would hurt I'd always
back I'll be out there in a minute now
we'd never go skate dude
oh you I see I would skate but then to
the wall girl when is your birthday
yeah David see what he thinks
mica whiskies racist
oh we're not friends at we say you want
yeah tag to each other we used to go to
the gym I did not have a number and I
want to get a cell phone either for the
best yeah
did you for your birthday cat mmm it's
usually preparation for July 4th because
my birthday is the day right before the
worst so you have your birthday for
Christmas
no day after Christmas right here Oh
worse not the highs Gunnar who's tired
yeah just a bunch of wrapping paper
I forgot how old I am no one
celebrates it mm-hmm Boldin Chin's the
oldest uh-huh I am the oldest right
yeah we're what are you 47 40 to 42 I'm
a second then I'll be 40 big four oh
dude back nine bruh back nine me me back
nine could live forever dude have you
seen Joe Rogan's have you seen the
raccoons outside of his house okay
one of them called me the other day good
point good point one of them emailed me
the other day they started their own
podcast red bands producing yeah and
they're also thinking about getting a
poke a drug yeah dude who brought his
poker who was it let's give a shout-out
to those guys what was a company called
hello hey boys hello hey boys hello a
boys my hair boys Mahalo Mahalo Mahalo
hello
good amazing you're headed to Hawaii
dude you'd be stuffed full of just come
back
what do you do for st. Patrick's Day
what are you doing what what do you ever
st. Patrick though Danica Patrick
celebrate st. Patrick's Day and like
kind of thinks it's like her thing do
you think Dan Patrick thinks it's his
national holiday dude they should have a
dananddana off and warning one of them
lives yeah that'd be cool who do you
think would win that Dan Patrick Verdana
Patrick Dana Patrick is Abby's dude yeah
Beiste she banshees will fight
what's-his-name intern Rogers and Rogers
so you know she's a little spark plug
get it she also she retired though yeah
yeah I mean she was also you know yeah
but also yeah she kind of they were
gonna win yeah yeah it's like she was
retired what she won the UH
she want I think you won one time yeah I
think she won more like the the box soap
box card thing yes she once I don't
watch NASCAR I don't want you is what a
peloton event she won the Japan 300
hundred her 50th IndyCar Series race in
April 20th 2008 you guys that's the only
one she won yeah everybody else must've
been high you say you say 2008 yeah or
all so that's why here's Japan has got
to be hit or miss no they drift in Japan
me to stay on the track they're drifting
around dude well drink Anita and he
doesn't stop with a k' dude and he
doesn't stop saying it man god it's
hurting me yeah really man unbelievable
swing low Sweet Chariot embo to carry me
home
we're excited for our birthdays are you
dude your boy here just eats meat you
don't want to know how my casserole
turned out no because I'm only
interested in good quality meats your
boys can be feet
yeah beef yeah how did you get it I beef
meat huh from my friend I told you okay
well what if I told you there's a little
thing called butcher box and they're
helping me be carnivore I'm a carnivore
oh yeah you're carnivore you look at
that you're like one of his answers yeah
like a t-rex where's the Stegosaurus huh
like a CTE Rex yeah come on do it
come on do it now kill me that's an
Arnold we're talking about his butcher
box we tell these people or not yeah I'm
gonna tell you I'm gonna tell you how
you can get 100% grass-fed telling me
free-range organic chicken it won't be
like a t-rex you want a march through
life go bra in tread City and you do any
boy yeah dog just butcher box butcher
box believes everyone deserves the
highest quality humanely sorts meat on
the planet back off the mics ball what's
up every month but your box get some
meat straight into your stupid mouth
high-quality meat right to your home
meet me you knock knock who's there
meat boy knock knock the best meat ship
right to door which means one less trip
to the grocery store box has nine to
eleven pounds of meat that's it you know
there's different possibilities there
how much meat enough for 24 individual
meals look or two people with
coronavirus milling around you never
know if you got to have that meat stash
you know never know dude it's packed
fresh it's shipped frozen and it's
vacuum sealed you know it stays that way
and it's also butcher box the most
affordable convenient way to get healthy
humanely raised meet with butcher box
you the highest quality meat around for
six dollars a meal then they even have
free shipping nationwide some Alaska and
Hawaii um right now our members are
getting ground beef for life that's two
pounds of ground beef in every box for
life of their subscription plus $20 up
that's crazy deal plus when I was off
the first box just go to butcher box
calm /ke 80s or just yell out through
nothing will happen but go to butcher
box.com / k 80s yup k 80s at checkout
we're talking ground beef for life son
that's two pounds of ground beef and
every box of the life year subscription
plus $20 off your first box butcher box
calm / k oh look I got to tell you
straight up man straight up straight up
your boy oh don't drink water I know you
don't and that's why I'm hydrated no
doubt dude no doubt and that's why I'm
trying to change your life and when I'm
whoa whoa wake up and what I'm trying to
offer you man
is liquid IV okay dude you get back from
the gym or something instead of just
having a glass of water throw a liquid
IV in there you stir it up takes four
seconds boom you down it dude it's like
drinking eleven glasses of water yep
whole weather you hydrated try liquid IV
is the fast most efficient way to stay
hydrated
oh I'm not joking one stick in 16 ounce
of water hydrates you two to three times
faster and more efficiently than regular
water to get that stick in my body dude
you get the vitamin C the b3 b5 b6 and
b12 you might have an even an f15
because you're gonna feel like a damn
fighter jet dude it's a fast-growing
wellness brand there is you can find
them everywhere find liquid IVs
hydration multiplier your local Costco
Whole Foods alright it's a worthwhile
choice I'm telling you I went through
I'm not joking I went through the three
boxes that they sent me I went through
them probably in a week and I felt saucy
your skin looks good thank you I feel I
feel hydrated so when you take liquid IV
do the same hydration or drinking two
three bottles of water like you said
that's not student that's liquid IV Tom
promote a TS and you save 25% off maybe
our Spring Break coming up maybe you got
that holiday party you me do a little
booze it may become one of my shows one
of Theo's he's sober mind we get pretty
wild so I like to stay hydrated be
hydrated with your boy here get ready
stay hydrated get dripping it's the
taste I love it man I got a couple of
different flavors get 25% off when you
go to liquid IV calm and use code cats
at checkout
that's liq UID i v.com and enter promo
code cats to save 25% off and get better
hydration I'm not I'm not joking this
the best stuff I've ever used yeah don't
wait start properly
driving today get into this episode dude
should we get in some cats rap battle oh
it's back mm-hmm that was weeks ago
haha weeks ago weeks ago they tried it
we show they tried it he goes this is
life yeah yeah yeah mmm yes I read for
me both speaking out before we get into
contenders we thought we had our first
female rapper she sent this in on
Twitter and let's give it a listen and
we're here with Michelle Mena spoken
word poet and what are you gonna do for
us today Michelle all right well let me
sit back then go ahead Michelle
[Laughter]
you want to just read something from
your book well so last week we had
Danvers Papa Bear and in the first round
Don beat Papa Bear like 77238 old and
then little brows retained his crown
against Don 71 to 29% so I walk out the
little brows in the crowd oh wow girls
gone wild been a bit with all dudes yeah
dudes gone wild that little browse this
dude's got wall to my crown dude it's
fantastic that's beautiful man it's nice
to see a bunch of young men enjoying
themselves yeah positive attitudes
shirts off what's this so we got two new
contenders this week two-faced little
brows and the videos just keep getting
more and more produced this first one is
from a rock AR a a ra ra D is his name
and his artist name is a highs a hy es
and this is dedicated one of the
greatest human beings and souls I've
ever known my biggest supporter my best
friend Ryan Charlie
r.i.p that's what it says
ah yes okay us can't get a stay and game
bus shoutouts to make Riga Aryan man
guys you gotta make love to the king of
this thing the Rat King gets the King
gonna stink the King
Thank You Brandon you look like the king
of the twist and I'm shoutouts to CTE
cuz thinking is not really his empty
kasi invincible drinks Theo looks like
the type of guy to wash his dick in the
sink London I'm joking you're killing it
from the jump
my niece and nephew love you so go ahead
and pump this pump many podcasts out
ever what divides is talent that's the
higher than Derek high advantage y'all
can laugh at ease like an average
comedians like that birds looking to
Lear the ex-fighter guy in the child of
Bryan Callen Oh every way wait wait my
bad ex-fighter linen shop [__] man I
apologize let me switch it up y'all need
to fly me out they say
to go on a date with Canada
[Music]
bring out your problems and relate with
that go home and magically I'm just
joking my bad
I'm not joking either
[Music]
Gang Gang bus
okay buzz
[Music]
gay [__] jack you like ariana grande
love it
no soap Angra is really dope oh yes
music
Mikey bingo beats that was fun
it was good man that's a good buy oh
it's fun for sure yeah definitely
definitely different than the rest
it's a good vibe you know ways you to
put the top down the tits out yeah
definitely like that beat that it kind
of has that Moroccan zombie-like I could
rock to that Moroccan I said man pop a
couple of Coronas get jean shorts out
rollerblades mics hard yeah a couple my
cards maybe a Zima every now and then oh
I think you said Mike's hard all that's
our next rapper we got no this oh this
is Johnny C Oh Johnny C boy oh yes from
Georgia before I begin let me just say
[Music]
let me show you what a real web sounds
like just so y'all have some contacts
dude it's the King and the sting which a
crop on the B thickness and sickness by
shop CBD or feels tattoo dancers an
ecstasy slip the rodents a few now shots
on ketamine do checked in tougher
pornography I swear they got cat if I
don't see your feet I'm crashing into an
embankment and New Orleans gang gang
buzz-buzz sting sting
kocha push the back strap another for
you bring chairs haunting again and
attach it to the playground bacon bells
Claudia still a little brown get a wax
called me to sue the village I was born
in the doctors y'all faking it I say on
the road rules you should do the same
I gave you a lane now stay in it before
a call and the kids talk history again
roasting hopes lock knots
busting nuts and climbing cars getting
gay birds gang gang
[Laughter]
no rap king is beasting my gangs buzz is
no hey [__] whoa that's how you say he
wants some whiskey that Chappelle teeth
gave to Wow man dude he went and that
was real it was probably more or less
produced maybe I don't know was it I
don't know anything Browns like this
well now the brows can bring up that
monster lebra's oh shoot something uh
whoever shoots something up wins it okay
dude we're not doing that on this
episode also that guy was pretty
gangster they're both good man yeah both
really good you try and see who's gonna
be little brows mhm it's just a
different vibe like a little brows is on
that [__] how many straight has a hit
on 105 nine
well I yes music - the first guy the
first guy his was a hit - different
though here's more of a beachy hit
somebody's getting married at the beach
or somebody this bored
he also did sing yeah I did hit that
Drake on it yeah he had a little more
Drake on it
I didn't some of the verses I didn't get
that much but it was good though but it
was cool he went after cat hard he would
have - cat hard any interests on that
man - big
very I don't like the attention
it makes me blush uncomfortable well
he's very nice though he looks like the
it looks like the bad guy and like in
the goofy cartoons the big guy
you don't talking about yeah you know
interrupt out the real big one
it looks like Kelvin Gastelum if he
never fought and just hung out a
beautiful wild fare he looks like Aaron
Donald for the Aaron Donald for the RAM
yeah he looks like your dog for the rail
this guy you mean no no the other disc
Alex a gerund on oh no no the big guy
looks like Aaron Donald you know he's a
gentleman if Eric Donald was in a
[__] WeHo
gay parade yeah yep the jean jacket all
low again that's yeah yeah that's him
wrapping a cat right there look man look
I think browse has both these guys they
look identical you know God's sakes oh
that's not a bag call me you're right
come on son
I think Brian I don't know I'll put it
up to the people but on my end what do
we do cuz I don't know yeah he looks
identical oh yeah references to them
good yeah I represent on point today I
don't know what we do cuz I don't know
if anybody's can beat little brows he's
that good
is he done fans love well he's
destroying everybody but somebody's got
to come at him brah no one no one's come
close the last one was dawn I thought
Dom would get close Don said he has a
remix that he wants to send in so maybe
next time we do it if little browse wins
again we can put them up against each
other a little rematch but okay all
right so do we have a contender from
today wins browser no I'll go around the
room okay hmm chin container today
against to go get little bras I like the
rawness of the last guy he's very raw he
was on like right there yeah but I don't
think they yeah I think they could
compete
what Browse yeah I'm gonna go with that
second guy even though he's extremely
aggressive he had really good lyrics
although it's kind of cheating to just
use our segment titles to rhyme cuz they
all rhyme anyways but he was still
better yeah we kind of did the rhyming
for you yeah pre rhyming I think I'm
gonna go with the second guy like his
aggression I like the aggression on the
first guy by like the the flavor the
first guy what did you say I liked so
the second guy had better rhymes but the
the the the first guy was more fun in
word again Oh joking man look I've said
I know how it feels when people hear you
say it's not cool man
people thought Don last he said Nixa gee
everybody thought he was saying n-word
but he didn't oh if he's straight I
would have called it that's a good point
I'm staying that look brows is still it
I these guys are thank you very much for
the submission they're great yeah
they're great
I don't know who's gonna come along be
brows but I thought that dominican guy
went straight at brows though I think we
do what we did last week we put those
guys up against each other in a vote and
then the winner faces three miles oh
yeah
yeah then they can get crushed by little
brows it's a mile around there dude
Oh bro Road sometimes I just like to get
down the ground oh go ahead sniff that
green you're going in grass bro do yeah
oh you like a little cattle boy yeah duh
do what I'm telling you about is right
now I got something tasty for you
something naughty dude can I be honest
when I was a kid I would daydream that I
was Jolly Green Giant oh yeah yeah
that's not you didn't have to be honest
I thought that I knew that all right the
one thing that health experts dieticians
athletes and top performers agree on is
that the perfect diet doesn't exist
no it don't with a balanced healthy diet
you are going to cover all your
nutritional bases but you can't do it
through food alone
I need that green sauce in my mouth I'm
talking athletic greens the ultimate
daily on one health drink with 75 proven
vital minerals whole food source
ingredients makes it easier for you to
get the nutrition you need how long no
pills none of that athletic greens
includes prebiotics probiotics your
mama's biotics robotics whatever you
want Larry by greens is what you need
all I'm doing I'll give them watch you
need give a grain in your weed delivered
in powder form and mix the water I
thought it greens requires less capsules
has superior absorption and does
include any binders or fillers hello
baby what athletic greens provides
convenient affordable and tasting
solutions to fill the gaps in your dying
about it again
75 vitamins bra look whether you're
talking whether you're taking steps
towards a healthier lifestyle or you're
just talking about it either way and let
it greens is gonna help if you're an
athlete pushing for better performance
it's definitely gonna help athletic
greens takes the guesswork out of
everyday good health you don't know if
you're in a produce section you gotta
have a carrot or two beets or whatever
or you got to jam a celery down your
whole bra try shoving a whole head of
lettuce down your mouth I feel bad when
I'm talking about is go to athletic
greens comm /k ATS and claim our special
offer today 20 free travel packs valued
at $79 with your first purchase
that's athletic greens calm / K 80s get
green all right let's get into this man
let's get into this dang episode let's
do a dog sweet we got some debate club
here's the first one
oh is this that guy from Young Sheldon
this guy looks like a young Sheldon does
a little bit if Sheldon was Asian
yeah young dumb sorry Oh young boys
debate club for you last night I was
with my lady at the den on Sunset and I
believe I saw chin with a nice lady and
I wanted to say like you know like big
fan so I wanted to make is your name
chin cuz I was only 99% but that felt a
little inappropriate you know you can
walk up to a white guy and say is there
any man true but inappropriate or
appropriate to walk up when you're 99%
sure and say is your name chin
great great great English great question
it's a great question here what was it
set on sunset
the Danoff sunset sunset all right boys
debate club for you last night I was
with my lady at the den on Sunset Dan
off sunset I don't remember going to the
den maybe were you off sunset sunset
someone was out with a different girl
than his girl yeah sounds like the den
off sunset well you were out with that
girl again Carlito what's her name tits
tits tits Hansen Tina - he caught the
predator I think I was there
wow wow you to google it yeah looking
through his where his phone has been
over the past couple weeks I think it's
okay to walk down behavior you chin you
whether it's chin or not but he's saying
because chin is a very distinctive type
of name and chin appears Asian chin just
sounds very very like it could come off
somewhat racist right a little but not
my things young chin from firing the kid
or you know Steenkamp he thinks it's the
chin yeah you go up Gil you well you
should say are you Dutch in yeah because
that is less race Dutch in they talk
about Jay Leno that's yeah either way
you're good are you touching those go
hair you a chin that's racist yeah are
you a chin text David Duke okay people
say yes oh it's okay - yeah that's fine
it's not too bad yeah so I'm gonna King
that as well man is there anything
someone Keiko do you say that's
offensive if people call me redneck that
offends me kinda it does bother you
right when we first started sure I'd
make fun of you for being a redneck it
didn't go well
yeah I don't mind like sometimes I don't
mind if it's like in a funny instance
but if it's just somebody is just like
oh this redneck you know like being mean
to you well it's just yeah cause it's
just too much of a generalization it's
just such a boring like it's not
creative yeah it's not create week yeah
like off-putting kind of term yeah and
it's not really my vibe either really
yeah you know
not at all I don't think anyway no I
don't think so I mean I look like [__]
I'll agree to that
no I would call your redneck yeah I
wouldn't say red now you don't really
have I mean I guess they have it those
rednecks for sure I don't think really
in New Orleans I wouldn't consider ed
Nick's by you [__] South Carolina
probably as more but is it redneck
they're more of like a Texas traditional
I feel like in South Carolina you told
me you went to USC one time no I went to
USC oh yeah yeah you see this your
southern rednecks Oklahoma like got
Moore Oklahoma Texas Mike oh that Texas
is Western the Oklahoma is more of
Western I think I think a pickup truck
Confederate flag and yam Bui yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah so that would be like
Alabama Alabama West Virginia yeah West
Virginia has sort of Matt's not redneck
those are Mountaineers it's hillbilly
hillbilly they call it then maybe
rednecks don't exist no they do less and
less get out more brother I I think I've
been out get out more right I probably
did is there is there any term that
bothered besides redneck for him as a
term that bothers you chin nip like back
in the days I was younger they would
call you nips it was candies though I
know if see husky will say nips all the
time now even if so they'll call him nip
right yeah
like nip we sleep either one of the
worst derogatory terms for Asians I've
never owned one out of my life it's for
sure for Nippon Japanese but they called
every Asian nips
that's an it some smart bullies we do
that you never heard that cat nip no wow
that's that's before your time dude
everybody called me black as hell
Chappelle creative bullies that's what
about you Nick any term that would
bother you you can call me anything does
value it only bothers me if it comes
from
like people that know me if it's like
Internet people doesn't can't get done
by me you don't know I don't give a
flying [__] but if it's like someone
here yeah it would depend yeah my
friends a roommate way meaner than
anybody on the internet could be yeah I
mean feel can hurt my feelings once
anybody yep mm-hmm
should we go next Cantor's King
interesting it for the main club debate
club cat wait real quick anything that
bother you
I think I have the opposite reaction to
what yours is so like I don't want mine
can hurt you
not it doesn't even hurt me it's just
annoying cuz most of the time the jokes
aren't funny oh yeah I might done by
because they don't cuz they they don't
know anything about you so it's like
sometimes I wake up it's a Tuesday
morning the people are meeting you
online oh yeah no yes
let's guy that's like dorks in their
basement who like yeah I know yeah in
cells yeah also knows about like
everybody gets that that's fine yeah I
can't believe a just a hot girls I don't
know what their agenda I wonder what the
motive behind it is girls sometimes
really have to issues with other girls
let's get into this this lady knows
there's a lady right here that has so
maybe an idea so with Amanda Knox
getting married this week you got me
thinking for debate this foxy Knoxy
innocent or guilty
thanks game getting she guilty or
innocent she's one that killed her
daughter right no she was no rot in
Italia in Italy and she got accused of
killing her roommate and spent all that
yeah definitely did it yeah come on we
had her on this I don't think that she
did it right but I do think she'll Oh
Mike she looks like somebody over she
looks like somebody that could kill
somebody that's she has a look in her
eyes sometimes like oh yeah she could
kill someone yeah dude it's called dead
behind the eyes cuz they murder people
you've seen Oh Jay Simpson real life huh
you ever seen Oh Jason looks like you're
staring at a great white shark really
yeah Wow her same [__] boys time
ha did you guys have security here yes I
saw the documentary those things always
you know a long way we just talked about
what did we talk about all kinds of
stuff yep she just got married and her
and her fiance came Chris was that his
name yeah and they loved Renaissance
Fairs yeah she couldn't murder look how
she's very lean and kind of um uh does
she kill she you gotta be strong estab
someone I think you know you got to be
able to yeah yeah a little bit little
bit she's very like Connecticut she
dressed up like it's [__] game of
that's her wedding you don't link Quinn
yeah I know how [__] batshit crazy
gotta be to dress like [__] Game of
Thrones on your wedding day it's a
Renaissance Fair theme and everybody get
those giant dinosaur turkey legs and
outer space I'm not sure what food they
had she did it though watch the doc dude
just got it really he did I don't think
she did never did she kidnap Marilyn
Marilyn McCann I don't know she could
have done that Nick you're awfully quiet
over there what do you think you're
around this killer
I think she's capable of murder but I
don't think she did it okay Oh
now here's when you know if she kills
someone else that's how you know if
someone else around her dies usually
someone who's killing people can't only
kill one person as they can especially
the roommate Italy she didn't get away
with it
she had convicted of murder for god
sakes she got she they were unsure all
right she seems like a great young lady
and there's a man Don Knotts and which
is the one that killed her kid and then
wants more kids
Stacey Anthony Casey Anthony that's
right and Scott Peterson killed Casey
Anthony didn't he then who killed Jon
Benet is it the same guy I'm confused
I don't know I think japonaise brother
killed her Hanabusa oh my god I saw that
dang bro bring up JonBenet's brother you
see this no my name is on dr. Phil
repeal you got to get in here who do you
guys believe in serial killers or what
are you
one well there's been two DC sniper and
the Baton Rouge guy the nope the
Atlantic the Atlantic killer
oh wow Willie would oh you the brother
Oh leave that [__] psycho he killed
her because she she ate his pineapple on
milk hit over the head then the parents
covered it up because they don't wanna
lose both kids yeah you're like a song
really yeah yeah cold case what's his
name Larry Ramsey or something with the
brothers name Burke Burke Ramsey it
doesn't the jeweler yeah is that a
recent picture of he probably has been
playing a pickup game or something
looking like Chris D'Elia in that last
picture go to that lat right there no
zoom in go in
just the up a little he definitely did
it though up a little more yeah I see it
oh my god bro Burke D'Elia dude he
definitely did it though understand yeah
it was an accident Brendan if you killed
someone an accident you want to go to
jail forever for do you want your
parents to help you out here's another
thing no man is Chris Lee could
definitely play this guy in him if there
was a biopic well crystal hear him play
a killer but he plays like a pedophile
not killer in you second season again
yeah but I want to see him play this
dude I want to see him play Burt Burt
Bonet that's good that's actually
crystally on the right that's crazy
mix them up easily dude have you seen
that dating show on Netflix I just
watched the first episode yesterday love
is online you got to get past the first
one then he gets good it's already good
they're so good right love is blind if
you got seen this so it's like a group
like 12 and 12 12 dudes 12 girls there
in separate sides and then they meet for
days in these pods but they can't see
each other so they can only get to know
each other through a wall through a wall
but the kids see each other at all and
some of them get engaged yeah one one
dude starts crying yeah he's like will
you marry me this is crazy
no no four four days what and then she
this is black girl hot she's batty
and her family's like all about black
lives matter and like no she's never
dated a white dude before yeah she knows
she's talking to the [__] [__]
tall white Larry and they get men and
they get engaged and she's all Oh kisses
fantastic now he's the love of my life
don't tell me anymore but that my
favorite part she goes you know its
mission to bring him home you know
because he's like but we can still talk
about black lives and stuff like that
yeah and it seems like he definitely
he's from Maine that's the thing and
he's uh he's like the very robotic
engineer yeah I guess robotic engineers
are wider job go hmm or make spinach
artichoke dip someone catching crabs up
there in the water yeah that's fair that
could be Vietnamese though - yeah that's
a good show though have you guys seen it
no I thank you last night about it Ken
yeah it's worth checking out I just
watched one episode and had to go to
sleep would you go on the show huh
no oh but I did start to think a lot of
people would I'm curious to see because
yeah you start to you get to know
somebody so you have to know I mean you
can't have your phones all the time
you're there either so you totally like
just yeah it's like the ultimate fighter
but they don't fight each other what's
weird to me though is you know I know
it's not about looks but looks is a big
deal you have a type dude you have a
type so you get to know the person
submit they might check the box
emotionally but then you mean oh my god
I'm not into that that's not what I'm
into they make sense well I mean it's
love is blind is what did this show is
called and so it's a my favorite part
first episode Vanessa what was it what
mr. Williams is that that's the host
right
yeah she's like I don't know I'm Vanessa
Lachey they get to see everybody and
then Nick Lachey goes and obviously I'm
Nick Lachey
yeah like obviously [__] these people
don't know who you
that's our young hey Nick Lachey got
some slapper yeah back in the day 98
degrees yeah yeah hey what solo song
lunch Bell what's this with me Nick
Lachey hey pass me by how's it going
what's left to me because of you I do
what's left of me the hardest thing was
a bag that's 90 degrees though where's
Nick Lachey up there should we play this
we might have to cut out of the
youtubers we just have Chappelle scene
ah
played just like you divided what's left
of me yeah it's labs it's about justice
yep but the music video has his current
wife Vanessa Hudgens
I think of a smile on holiday
son this man watch my life pass me by in
the rearview mirror pictures frozen in
time I've spelled of the heart becoming
dear
Oh
[Music]
[__] that's that dumper banger you
should sing out on your own you don't
know that song can I get one more Nick I
know you're going tell you it was good
we got plenty time yeah don't give me
the other pic any hits fool
dude go to 90 degrees getting nickel
share my [__] face what yeah like
anybody's ever said those lines before
share my [__] nose go to 98 degrees
get Nick Lachey I I Do's pretty doll
bust me with some O'Town get me off this
get this get out my face
yellow tiling it all this is that banger
make you feel play any of this on the
episode whatever
it's that banger dawg you don't know the
[__] should I can cry at the gym of this
[__] you [__]
[Music]
I said hey Spencer's gonna Orange Julius
you always have a snack this one's got
the ball with my walkie-talkie and mrs.
Fields cookie you can see this to chip
after I could you better do it play all
five roll
[Music]
beat
feels like the oldest member of Old Town
still on tour his name is all you have
ro his name his damn what do you think
all those boys are doing how many are
alive out of the four he's not in it
anymore he doesn't male modeling oh yeah
fifty the boys were older than me when
they were no man Trevor panic he got
who's another one there's a black guy in
it light scanner boy light seems like
guy in what Oh town yeah now you got
Erik Estrada Latino um yet Erik Estrada
what song am I thinking about
yeah right there what was another big
band back then he looks the oldest now
that Bukka oh yeah a black guy aids like
[__] what Trevor looks good man shut
up gay as [__] yeah
sound gay but after a notion if
anybody's gay doesn't matter bro I
thought Guillory supported here that
Ashley Parker angel is that almost is
that a recent picture that man yeah he's
wild and bro that's the most famous one
your skin [__] he had a lot of he did a
lot of uh yes he does a lot of you saw
hey stuff I think yeah I think works out
deals trainer to my trainers like yeah
but this is barbell in your but a [__]
you see that one with his dick out and
of yoga pants is that him yeah he
packing heat though just go to his IG
maybe I don't know if he's still alive
younger than hot no they're not dude yes
they gotta be older than us well older
me younger than you know sting they're
not did you go to his Instagram I'm
telling the gay stuff - not gay bro look
at this stuff it was modeling
yelling man oh yeah click on one of them
then you go straight dude takes picture
with banana
[Laughter]
I'm not mad at the lats though I'll give
them that boy you got some tips on how
people not get enough vitamin D
commercial for him what's going on there
do you pressure and oh yeah yeah
straight guy takes a picture with a
football like Dunn's look at the bottom
last one hey everybody who you going for
dude that's him waiting for food or so
what's the caption looking for the one
night al verse early bird who's with
verse exhausted peacock and fit is that
[__] nah man I don't have any probable
promise good any faster dude he's
looking for his friend is probably
parking outside a window I'd say wow
that's a legit question though go back
to the football one man that's a that's
more definitely more of a macho one yeah
hey big game today everybody who you
going for it Niners or Chiefs I suck
[__] oh wow he's an xxx FL fan you guys
don't know a gay man when you see him
man y'all got to look at more gay men
are you team Niners team chiefs or team
Jalen Shakira ha ha
comment below I'm eating wings and
chatting up doomsday man he's having a
problem with it at all he's crying one
more pull up me one more not the one
with banana that's too easy
he's too easy he's got a kid right it's
about potassium y'all jhanas kids there
you Elton John has kids he'd go that is
to keep going Ricky Martin has kids keep
going yeah but they're not real kids
they're backup dancers just cause some
kids yeah look at that one look at the
seasonal one oh yeah like this Christmas
normal patron sky would take well we got
a gift from somebody thinking his friend
arrived with the gift yeah this is
normal he just woke up like give me one
give me one more Nick this to be
positive he's not gay
oh there is in the shower that's normal
let me see that one
oh yeah good point yeah yeah that's what
every guy takes me is a shower that's
normal dude he's getting out of the
shower it says scary movie is the
caption misses MW faggins into it yeah
she's every comment click on her profile
for me Nick you got to know what's going
on here there's not that's a tragedy all
right
that's mr. smw Fagin yes oh well hey
this cold case all hokey had freaking
aluminum in it
not pokey had melatonin it doesn't I
don't they're killing some sleepy fish
dude there's a lot of tired fish out
there today no I was out fishing the
other day and two fishes got in the boat
can we now be not cut our heads off sure
do man we were swimming for 15 years
some [__] exhausting is a fishy here
we go here's the guy that's dead that's
doing something
Moses Jon Lovitz we got one more a
debate club what's up Brandon what's up
video so play it got a big club drop the
Crime Dog Smokey the Bear me personally
I prefer friendly bear and a hats
telling you not to light any forest
fires over some shady ass dog trying to
[__] lure kids and now is where the
stretch going on
trying to get the snitch on the friends
for bringing cigarette to school and
saying bad words and [__] that's just me
personally let me know what you guys
think
McGruff
well obviously smokey is his he needs
smokey right now I mean if you didn't
notice there's a fire behind ya there's
a lot of fun you can't see the huge fire
the guy pants - which is really close
wait he's a fireman
is he a fireman looks like it yeah I
think so
so obviously he's gonna be team Smokey
the Bear Smokey the Bear is preaching
the the Lord's word you know I'm saying
like this fires in California and that
beer does let you know don't smoke
around here yeah that smokey the [__]
McGruff the Crime Dog dude yeah like he
said trying to get kids a snitch on
other kids he's always in that trench
coat remember he was like right like
holy kids
yeah where the weird videos he's like oh
yeah boos he's like oh he's like weird
you could tell he ain't seen his wife
and kids in a while definitely sniffed
out by the real thing ex McGruff crime
the dog player gets prison for a
thousand plant pot farm and weapons
cache a so look well are they bust yeah
judge the man in the suit but look man
McGruff I think his point McGruff is the
first line of defense because if
somebody if you McGruff is saying don't
do cigarettes don't do we don't do that
Molly and [__] like that holy Joe to
McGruff was a [__] [__] clown what
did you say well it was big rough part
of deer take a bite out of crime take a
bite out of crime
yeah sorry Harry Caray dude I think I
was he was either deer mousy I was lyin
Dan here was the real [__] dude I shout
out to [__] Big Bob that was our dare
rep and he [__] over
you didn't overdose but he died because
he was overweight he overweighted
the shop and our school shouts officer
Stacy passed away from lung cancer
smoking as well did he and he was our
dear representative dude dear reps to go
down but it's a hard job do did you have
Jump Rope for Heart
no we haven't come with anyway I've jump
rope far in here
where they'd come over and they're like
professors jump ropers oh god yeah they
start [__] live and dude what this is
the Dare line this was the mascot mm-hmm
Darrin was the Dare mascot dude I'll
smoke that dude bro that line makes me
want to do drugs I'll do a gram off of
that Tiger's tail bro that dude I'll
take Somali and talk to Darren I'll say
that right now
[Music]
i blaze a [__] a ball straight into
my veins yeah Darren I'm Nolan Ryan a
couple of Hawks he's right down my
throat I can get out there and take a
little Darren Darren ain't scaring
nobody out of drugs dude he had a guy he
would always tell us that it wasn't
really him in the suit we had like some
guy was like scale like he had like uh
claustrophobia or something dude any
like hey it's me Alan in here what we
didn't know him bro he didn't go to
school or anything is it get Alan wants
you know it's out no he wouldn't lift it
up he would just say it oh yeah dude my
my brother's old mean him and his buddy
went to Red Robin real the big bird Red
Rock and always cover around my
brother's Freddy goes I bet you won't
slap that Robin I'm like yeah I was
younger I was a guy well and the Robbie
came around I was a kailath yeah I'm
like eight it is like this oh my dad got
so bad maybe this one made it worse
so the guys like it was a black guy boy
sorry that sounded like a black guy
getting a little big he walks away my
dad's like bad dude makes me go to the
back and there were my dad's okay my son
hit the Robin he wants to apologize to
him and we get
some some old black guy just that was
the last straw
I think he quit after that day but it
made it worse that my dad maybe
apologized to him just like hey man I'm
sorry dude
- oh yeah yo did debate that way words
damn but you have to go apologize
Brennan you [__] hit an a you hit an
endangered species first Red Robin but
the best part about the suit [__] final
straw dude this guy would be like don't
do drugs my guys working for steak fries
that should we close it out with some
punk my uncle you haven't done that in a
while
let's see his little punk ass oh my
cheeks hurt but I don't know what your
ass your face face this is a funky
Jerome sent in by Brandon Springer Rome
Rome
dude Hibiya is he he's always sleepy
okay
he eats chips and cookies for breakfast
and washes him down with a nice cold
Mountain Dew his favorite jokes are
farting poop jokes and he once got hard
watching lady [__] in the woods is it
Stephen Hopkins and outdoorsman uh oh
dude he's out that Nexen be sore in the
morning brother yeah happens on planes a
lot and who's that somebody's uncle yeah
this is uh Brandon's uncle yeah Brandon
your uncle glad he's gonna hit a few
people there he is
and that's right before he cut his wife
off a killer from from the documentary
stairs have you seen that what do you
guys think when you see a guy like this
and it's what do y'all think about what
do ya see we see an old man that he got
like that ah there he is right there it
is at a Funeral that was before he knows
after I guess also he chopped up his
wife I mean you see a lot of that in
Arizona I'll tell you that much and what
does that mean when you see it man yep
give me an M you were thinking he was
trying to come back to sleep he just
wanted me to say it did they say what uh
what he does for a living yeah
sleeps at work looks like he has
important job look it looks like so he
makes alarm clocks he was testing one
out right here didn't you see him get
taken and it's behind him on the left
looks like he's deal with some serious
[__] dumb yeah what is he doing he's oom
in on that left picture please no rocket
scientist look at the ship behind he's a
rock scientist that dude smoking that
right he's a rocket time out solo he
cleans up nice though he's got a scale
what else is he doing now what's in his
hand there paintbrush he's a painter
Brendan you don't think MIT Bengt
dude this might be the 20th century this
is a trap house he's making drugs bro
well it's a very nice trap house well
look there's all those markings on the
floor what does that mean that's like a
lab I was like warning it's a lab he's
in a suit yeah
you have any information about this man
neck just all the cookies and Mountain
Dew and [__] here's another video he's
farting
yep but it was because that the bouquet
of middle fingers oh well I like that
this guy's huge hands - can we look at
his hands there at the very end of that
but you know look at his big meters you
don't see a lot of large handed men like
that anymore big he's very kind of
Paleolithic if you will peel it it's
like cool uncle look I'll say this at
least he walked outside to pass gas a
lot of minimal do that do they do that
in Asian culture chin pass gas yeah yeah
but just quietly yep it's not as big of
a deal this what he what he said was a
I've never heard my mom fart in my own
entire life he's got brother my mom will
let it rip bombs over Baghdad see yes oh
my mom would Dutch up in me when I was a
kid oh yeah I think you heard your mom
fart so I'm looking for my birthday
we got one more Punk my uncle what is it
witness say Patrick how could you ever
get the sound out of your ears
my mom yes dude my mom one time had to
[__] her pants so bad I was a kid she
parked in emergency lane in the middle
of the mall
left me in the car ran and [__] and then
came back and got me
yeah that's being a mom dude but how do
you your fart is still going about the
delighted laugh for a syrup a big
farting laughs I've never heard any of
my dad's dead but I never heard my mom
fart my mom thank god I couldn't handle
it and chin you said in your and your
culture it's not even cool huh you guys
want you have sex loud like this it's
like - yeah it's just like your penis
and vagina just trying to keep a secret
yeah it's a one big secret it's a
sausage boss nobody busts
tonight does that mean anything
I mean Dodge Viper yeah I'll try saying
that whiskey Oh David Duke just text he
say I'm gonna say that all right what do
you got this is uh sent in by Lewis from
Illinois
this is uncle slick Victor he's 50 years
old he likes to watch Japanese wrestling
while hitting his vape he's a retired
stripper but now works in a warehouse he
got married and fall of last year in
Vegas at an Elvis Presley themed
drive-through Chapel and he's currently
just a couple pieces of paperwork away
from getting a divorce
hey men oh yeah he's got a beautiful
fish on him let's see uh it almost sort
of videos the fish almost fake oh
there's no video yeah just this guy
that's beautiful out there he's out
there by a lake look at that it's a
beautiful fish yeah it's got a nice
sunny on him a couple Reds maybe carp go
through divorce
oh yes fun but keeping his head up slick
vic they call him up
kids catch Slick Rick at the lake yep
he's got a good smile I like the name of
it I likes anything I brought my slick
is usually a good name I feel like slick
vic prick slick dick trick no not any
word just any name that rhymes are slick
is good yeah I know I'm just give me a
bunch of names those are names slick
brick
Rick Rick Lee tick tick I knew it tick
um here's a lifeguard though there's a
mistake don't want that guys what he I
see don't want don't want him relying on
saving my life
take the lifeguard no absolutely dude my
sister Mary kids almost like drowned she
was like underwater and some guy jumped
in and saved her and then came back and
saw us like years later and was wearing
just jean shorts and no shirt and he
came back
this guy sounds like a goddamn hero and
he was looking for a date I don't know
my mom was like what the hell are you
doing here likes almost 7:00 p.m. all
right Victor didn't really take us
anywhere so we'll close it out with two
quick sync my inks he's due Vic sucked
here's our first he's been through hell
okay they said he was in Vietnam he was
in Holi the other thing is a stripper
clothes though here's our first thing
buy ink today I have a sinking
submission - it was a happy little
accident well we'll watch the rest of
this one I'll just skip right to the
next one right now I saw that Miami
porno can't give a Japanese what is that
a snake yeah it's just a snake egg you
prob raw power collar bone whatever you
want to call it I don't know what it is
and then just below that some modest
mouse lyrics this is the part of me that
needs medication Thanks yeah life's
crazy out here over here got that crazy
black flag bars logo wall power black
player I got my best friend shouts out
to CJ Hill is he still alive
you know we're here bro got them misfits
fiends
I got that when I was really drunk
cheering some game in Florida and then
last but not least that demon system 13
another punk-rock baby shower sent over
swedish thrash game buzz buzz good yeah
is he still alive you think a black guy
has a tattoo of someone who's still
alive on her yeah that's awesome
but dude but rest in peace yeah PC I
talk
oh damn that's you getting the tattoo
yeah now he's Joe Rogan with hair giving
you the tattoo that's pro-roh Deron
Coleman man how long did you get that
raw power - that was two years ago that
[__] was horrible
yeah that was the most painful probably
more painful ones yeah David tattoos are
intense bro yeah that could be Joe Rogan
with hair doing tattoos Arizona damn go
bra powers from an album yeah it's an
album by Iggy Pop and the Stooges it's
also a song and then modest mouse what
was the most famous modest mouse hold on
we all flown on all right hey why'd you
look that look as you saying it's so
aggressive
well alright then Lupe Fiasco sampled it
yep great
yep Brendan so what I'm saying is this
dude um does what I'm saying is else
tattoos a pretty dope it's late your
only tattoo cat have another one yeah
yeah oh my rip what is it
it's a CS Lewis quote Oh CS Lewis an
author
it's a ck Lewis quote which quote is it
cat there's nothing worse than to
explain tattoos is there I hate it
would you get that [__] cuz I wanted to
write there's a whole segment cuz I like
I know you personally know someone you
know like Julia got a tattoo I was like
oh that's I was like watch it I mean you
have to explain why you got it let me
just see the art that's cool dude I
think that fish had something minute bro
iron or something leave sleepy it's
called work y'all yeah I gotta get that
does it I feel good yeah your tattoos
are pretty cool if people didn't know he
just had your shirt off like oh he
served ten years oh yeah but they get
closer like or it's a thrash amazing
about that boy killer them jean shorts
years ago it wasn't a boy that was a man
dude mr. Lantz
oh wow mr. Lance came with him genius
Levi's nice though they might have him
Rossler or something they would pretty
look they might believe us he come over
today I'm looking for a little ruffles
he wanted to see my sister again because
he'd saved her life he said so he says
like what do you do in here you don't
have any shoes on there you have it
Jesus let me see that little sisters are
you I mean yeah this weekend anywhere
dude I'm so glad you asked my back hurts
Britton is it cool do
I mean uh I'm in Atlanta Friday
Buckhead theater once you only I'm in
New Orleans
the next night your hometown tell your
peeps come on out Gang Gang the dark
arts rollin through but I'm not really
that dark more like the bright arts New
Orleans March 14th one night only then
Austin March 19th through the 21st and I
in the month
Toronto Detroit Minneapolis get your
tickets one night only in every city
except Austin gang that sounds amazing
man it's gonna be fun
could be we'll see we'll see bro it will
be man I'm coming up I'm gonna be at the
Ryman at April 17th and I think got sold
out in Nashville and outside of that um
that's all I know right now and then
we're gonna be shooting a special
somewhere but I don't know where you
doggy any ideas we want to shoot it um I
don't know actually
well Alice or Chicago maybe hmm
be cool yeah and then I'm shooting a
live podcast about this past weekend at
the Netflix Festival and I want to do a
live King this thing but I'm I'm in
Europe I'm sorry brother we'll do it
next time man we'll do it next time
um Chappelle Kat thank you guys thank
you yeah thank you gentlemen
Chappelle be with me in Austin y'all
yeah Austin Texas March 19th to 21st
Hard Day's 18th holla bring gifts to the
show bring him some whiskey - what's
that whiskey you like
[Laughter]